50 seconds of logos ah I see this movie
is about both life and death if it'd
been small or puny it was sickly or
misshapen it would have been discarded
the margin of error for a visual
inspection such as this is probably
insanely high child abuse is the only
way to ensure your kid becomes a badass
warrior fight diaper is is customary in
spot wait is the whole movie gonna be
narrated good to show no pain no mess at
what point is the kid not supposed to
show pain because he's showing a lot of
pain here Warner Brothers brings you
Zack Snyder's Sin City and sure the boy
given up for dead returns to his people
to secret Sparta by King King so we've
just been told that all Spartan men go
through the pit that Leonidas did
starting at the age of seven
other than the fact that he's a king
what was so special about this story
didn't they all go through the same
thing
Zack Snyder films if it looks real
you're not trying hard enough if you
made all the slow-motion shots in this
movie real time the total run time would
shrink to 22 minutes the king of Sparta
sounds awesomely Scottish for this
region
oh the cameraman fell in after the
Persians he was filming in order to make
jumps up a cliff less daunting Spartan
training includes a visual effects
course was I supposed to take drugs
before I watch this I mean I totally
could have if only I'd known this is
racist until someone tells me it's not
racist I'm gonna go ahead and consider
it racist Leonide ass also all of Sparta
can see the Kings dingaling if they
happen to look out their windows roll
credits and the captain completely lied
he said all the soldiers had sons to
carry on their names and what's worse he
says he has others who could replace him
what a dick where the fuck did they come
from only the hard and strongly :
Spartans okay sounds good Oh need a
heart
under the stroke I heard you the first
time
double flute guide cheese they assembled
the 300 warriors just this morning how
did word get to this group of soldiers
so fast let's camp right on the edge of
a terrifying drop-off why because it
makes a cooler shot little kid lives
just long enough to tell Leonidas what
happened
[Music]
we'll put them to the test
this is pretty gruesome but damn what a
waste of time this is clearly long
shadows on a dirt surface but in the
previous shot we saw that the floor is
all stone so then this shadow has to be
throwing itself out of her room down the
stone steps and onto the dark courtyard
except as we saw a moment ago there's
tons of cool moonlight bathing the
courtyard without a trace of that torch
light coming from a room more arts and
crafts with dead bodies I'm guessing
people back then had blood made of glue
or cement or something how do you
coordinate a job like this put a few
rocks down now it's time for a dead body
a few more rocks here now another dead
body so wait what were they gonna use
for mortar if they didn't have cadavers
wow this guy really thought his whip was
gonna do something in this situation I
mean he just saw it
gruesome dead body wall and thought my
whip will take care of the people who
did this it is I mean it's been thrown
together with carcasses man is there
something about corpses that make a wall
strong also where are all those Persians
that landed on the beach there were tens
of thousands of them and now they're all
gone except for a dozen Scouts killed
for the wall or is the main base of
operations where the book is everything
in relation to each other yeah
especially rejected hunchbacks whom you
should have heard cursing your name just
a second ago
[Applause]
five informations using this logic there
should be an earthquake
every time the Persian army moves yeah
man that's the whole plant right stay
here let them come to you why would any
of the Spartan soldiers be about to run
off somewhere everyone in the battle
gets quiet when someone yells now
Leonidas told The Hunchback guy that he
had no use for him in the battle because
he couldn't hold his shield up high
enough for the Phalanx but what are
these dudes doing back here they aren't
doing anything hunchback couldn't do and
what about when the battle gets to this
point in the open field
you couldn't use at least one hunchback
here Leonidas throws his spear and hits
one guy but two guys go down what are
they conjoined twins jeez if they'd send
more than one Persian at a time at him
they could take out the King pretty and
easy Leonidas is kicking some major ass
luckily he's the only person that we
will ever care about in this 300 Spartan
army no reason to show the other guys
I'm sure they're kicking ass in their
own way but who gives it bread why does
the rest of the massive Persian army
pause and wait while the Spartans drive
this small group of Persians off a cliff
oh I see it's so that we can get this
shot great awesome also a second ago
this cliff was wide the Spartans were
eight or nine wide pushing them off but
then in this glamour shot it's a skinny
cliff with just one or two Spartans out
in front doing the pushing how did the
Unitas forget about these assholes
these bred from birth badass warriors
all stand in awe of the obvious arrows
for 10 seconds before anyone thinks to
yell for them to take cover yeah you
showed those arrows who's boss by the
way how did you get your spear back you
threw it into the Batista twins a minute
ago you were using your sword and the
arrow attack happen right after that
movie reads my mind about what I want to
see and keeps cutting back from the
battle scenes to riveting shots of
boring life back in Sparta antagonist
says it would be unfortunate if
something happened to the protagonist
cliche the director said here eat an
apple it'll make you look like even more
of an asshole haha and there's the
reason the Apple was in the scene and
makes the we can't be civil line so much
funnier when you say it with a mouth
full of Apple ok so it would be stupid
for the Persians to kill Leonidas
because all of Sparta would go to war
but would it be stupid to just kill
Xerxes right here and now he has no one
defending him at all
I don't know the dreaded omen of the
seagull flying off a spear this guy will
fight for you but you need to put him in
Chains when you walk him to the battle
what is in Turks he's sent two armies
one to fight at the
gates and one to climb this easily climb
above body wall seems like an easy
strategy I don't know okay first why
would you scream and give yourselves
away like this and second of all why
didn't the leader of the Immortals take
some of the ten second head start
Leonidas gave him by shouting - I don't
know run away also I'd like to know how
this dead body pile did anything to help
the Spartans whatsoever they pushed the
dead bodies onto one dude it wasn't that
big a surprise that they were behind the
wall because The Immortals already had
drawn their swords I just think this
movie has a dead body fetish
and finally who's guarding the hot gates
right now every single Spartan is behind
the dead body wall why did the Immortals
even come to the wall in the first place
wouldn't the hot gates look completely
empty right now why was this immortal
dude running toward the monster guy was
it so the monster guy could show his
brute strength random acts shows up out
of nowhere on the battlefield when all
the Immortals use swords this is such a
weird fight scene the monster thrust his
sword towards Leonidas and somehow he's
able to stop it by crossing his arms
when it cuts back to the monster he's
got the blade and facing a fourth
somehow also Leonidas somehow holds off
the growling monster with one arm while
his other hand goes to pick up a random
dagger why desert seas in his
never-ending army of millions take the
night off
can't they enter into a simple attack
sleep attack sleep schedule we're
well-rested groups of soldiers can
attack and keep the Spartans from
getting any rest
arise bear witness to the grotesque
spectacle coughed forth from the darkest
corner observes his empire this
grotesque spectacle cough forth from the
darkest corner of Xerxes Empire is
huge rhino grotesque spectacle felled by
one measly spear 100 nations descend
upon us the armies of all age yeah but
one at a time no computers were harmed
in the making of the scene I officially
don't know what the fuck is going on in
this battle there were elephants falling
off cliffs and now they're on a
battlefield that looks like they're in
the middle of a desert somewhere and the
Persians keep sending unskilled fodder
towards the Spartans and expecting
anything to change why would you throw
your only weapon you have left at one
dude when there's plenty of other dudes
to kill well it's not like they're a
challenge or anything I guess well I
hope you're happy
you've just cursed your son to movie
hell right there oh no how will we ever
warn him in time skilled warrior somehow
doesn't hear a horse running behind him
and it takes about a month for him to
finally turn around to see it where did
the rider go
did he just ride in here cut a dude's
head off and disappear kept his cries of
pain at the loss of his son a more
frightening to the enemy than the
deepest battle drums what the army of
the Dead captained by an eight-foot God
is scared by morning morning was I
supposed to take drugs before I watch
this movie 300 crosses into rule 34
territory Josh can you just like use
your God power to make me not look like
sloth also Persian Shaq is a dick to
sloth we unite as his wife and salts the
only guy that can help her mmm hell has
a horrible rating on Yelp sarcastic
clapping cliche actually it's over
pretty quickly did the Persian mole
councilman just carry around his Persian
stamped gold coins everywhere he went
it's not like they'd be spendable in a
city at war with Persia come to think of
it why did he even accept that as a
payment in the first place it's
basically worthless to him steady
breathing
the 300 it is back there's nowhere near
300 of those guys left dude old leonidas
gives testament to our bloodline the
word we spread at bold Leonidas in he's
300 so far from home they down their
lives how does the narrator guy have any
idea what happened after Leonidas
cinammon with his message just standing
out here in a field just in case someone
wants to tell me my husband is dead
credits brought to you by a much cooler
version of the animated movie you just
saw
three-two-one
[Music]
do what we would great
you make a one-possession be
[Music]
and one more thing I want you never
for God is beautiful my dad's name when
boys and girls live in the same home
awkward situations can arise sometimes
I've heard even brothers and sisters
develop certain affections and when
those affections become common knowledge
well that is an awkward situation indeed
especially in a prominent family
prominent families often forget a simple
truth how much truth is that knowledge
is power when I say we're done
there is no gorge we hide now what are
you a treat what surrender no never give
up never surrender I have filled my
heart
let the heat flow through you